when you started talking about what
years things come from I pulled up like
the top 15 like I kind of repeat cards
and I wanted to quiz you guys okay go
ahead are we gonna buzz in here no you
just yeah yeah only Chrome Albert Pujols
20 no 2001 right notice I wasn't even in
that that was my dark era I want to give
a shout out to my dad completely [__] me
in this moment because he made me work
tirelessly from 1998. before Barry
Sanders oh nine yeah 90.
87 nope no 84 84 84 84 84. I think if
you go to the film I said 84 100th of a
second earlier a second I'm optimizing
for time not accuracy here I'm just
trying to win I'll take Aaron 54. I know
I know vintage tops Chrome Tim Duncan
97. last one cops football Jim Brown
when I tell you I needed that more than
life itself because I just got my ass
kicked